so there was a royal wedding over the
weekend I don't know if you heard about
it it was kind of an intimate affair
they weren't making a big deal about it
you know just invited a few of their
close family members so maybe you didn't
hear about it but and look I don't want
to get into a whole thing a whole rant
about what's the point of the royal
family it's so stupid I'm not gonna get
into that because although I don't care
about the royal family I do appreciate
in principle I appreciate the idea of
countries preserving their traditions
I'm a fan of that now this this
tradition has turned into a bit of a
soap opera too much for my tastes but
you know so whatever I'm fine with that
and anyway the Brits can do what they
want and if they want to spend money on
keeping the royal family together then
hey that's that's on them what what I
wanted to talk about was jumping off
using as a jumping-off point a tweet
that was sent out by a Twitter user by
the name of Yvan over the weekend and
she was commemorating this special
occasion of the Royal Wedding by
celebrating divorce and what Yvan said
was all my females if Meagan never left
her first marriage she wouldn't be
princess today there is always better
there is always better isn't that just a
great way to go into a marriage till
death do we part unless something better
comes along in which case I'm out of
here
sorry chump I'm gone now this
declaration wouldn't be notable except
for the fact that it has received last I
checked over 300,000 likes and something
like 80 or 90 thousand retweets
so obviously this marriage advice which
happens to be the worst marriage advice
ever recorded in human history resonated
with a lot of people in our culture
and so I think it's worth addressing
and fortunately I think that the bright
side is that it also provides a valuable
opportunity for all the single men of
America what you can do if you're a
single man or if you're dating if you're
good discerning marriage and if you're
with a woman before you propose what you
could do is what I would recommend if
she's on Twitter go on Twitter and
scroll through and and see if she ever
liked or retweeted or expressed any
endorsement whatsoever of that tweet
because a lot of women in America in
America did and if you see that they're
just run the other way as fast as you
can
just run I'm talking about even if you
were like sitting at dinner and and this
will be rude to do but if you happen to
check your her Twitter while you're
sitting at dinner with her and you saw
that then just get up from the dinner
table and run just run under the run out
of the restaurant don't even say goodbye
I'm out of here
because any woman who takes that view of
marriage is not suited for marriage and
is not suited for adulthood is not
suited for human relationships in
general
okay that's someone who just is I mean
that is selfishness and immaturity on a
scale unimaginable okay anyone who takes
that view stay away from now it should
be noted
that
Megan Markel
I did look this up for some reason well
because I was I knew I was gonna talk
about it so I felt like I needed to
Megan Markel did she is divorced and
according to a book that's being written
about her and interviews with people
familiar with the situation she
abandoned her husband just left her
husband one day out of the blue and
blindsided him he didn't see it coming
she just left him and I guess they were
when she decided this they were in
different parts of the country she
mailed him back her wedding ring and
just left them couple years later she
finds a richer and more famous guy and
decides to marry him and we're told
that when it went out when I've asked
women like why do you care about the
royal wedding what I've been told is
well it's like a fairy tale it's a fairy
tale romance is it really because in
order for this fairy tale romance to
happen another marriage had to be
destroyed and a man had to be abandoned
and the vows that she made to him she
had to break so she broke those vowels
and then she found this other guy that's
a fairy tale now that's not the kind of
fairy tales I'm familiar with
and sadly considering the rate of
divorce for second marriages is around
60% chances are this will not be the
last stop in her marital tour and when
you get to third marriages the rate of
divorce is like 75%
and I wish her no ill-will but the point
is you know it's not hard to see why
divorced people tend to keep on getting
divorced there's this domino effect of
divorce that happens it's not hard to
see why
because marriage
there's only two ways of looking at
marriage either it's a lifelong
unbreakable covenant or it's not
and if you've already been divorced and
you're getting married again well
clearly you think it's not and you're
taking that attitude with you into your
next marriage which is not a good way to
start
another way to frame it is like this for
Christians another the best way to frame
it is we're talking about marriage but
Jesus either defined marriage correctly
or he didn't and as it happens many
churches in America believe that he did
and they teach that he didn't well he
didn't know what he was talking about I
guess which is why they allow which is
why in so many churches they allow for
their members to get up on the altar and
make an undying until death do we part
commitment to a person and then come
back a few years later and make it to
another person and then another person
and another person even while the people
they're divorcing are still alive
so until death do we part and yeah maybe
not that's what many churches in America
that's what they've turned the marriage
vows into they've turned it into until
death do we part yeah you know maybe
that should be officially incorporated
into the marriage ceremony is just like
this this motion you know it's like yeah
yeah we'll see we'll see that's what the
church said them and in these churches
let's understand what's happening here
in these churches polygamy is completely
permissible because this is polygamy
according to Jesus this is polygamy
you're still married to the other person
the bond is still there you marry
another person now you've tried to marry
two people that's polygamy it's just
that now we allow polygamy in succession
rather than all at once but a man who
marries five different women is a
polygamist whether he marries them one
at a time at all or all at once doesn't
matter it's the same thing
but
if marriage is not a lifelong covenant
which I guess most Christians these days
think it isn't
then what is it
what purpose does it serve why bother
with it what if it's not permanent and
if you don't really mean it when you say
when you've out your undying commitment
and loyalty to a person why do it I
understand the legal benefits but in the
tax benefits let's put that aside for a
moment spiritually what's the point of
the exercise
it has been drained of its meaning and
its purpose in that case
and then all it is all marriages in that
case is just another thing you do hoping
it'll make you happy and if it doesn't
make you happy
and inevitably there will come a time
when you're not happy at least for a
season that's what happens in most
marriages you know it is not going to be
a state of unbroken euphoria all the
time there's going to be unhappiness
there's going to be oh you know anger
there's going to be all kinds of thing
so if you go into it thinking I'm doing
this to make me happy and then you're
not happy then you just you kind of
trade the marriage in like an
unsatisfying dish at a restaurant you
say well this this displeases me waiter
but take this away and brick yeah bring
me that over there bring me that on the
menu let me try that one instead
this is why I always say that most
churches in America gave up on marriage
destroyed it really long before the
homosexuals came knocking you know long
before there was any gay marriage fight
the churches had already abdicated they
had already given up when it comes to
marriage
by giving their blessings to rampant
divorce and remarriage
they had already removed from marriage
its entire point and that point again is
to be a spiritual and unbreakable
spiritual bond between man and wife a
bond that brings them closer to God and
which serves as the foundation for the
family
and when that bond is broken
than the to fall away not only from each
other but from God and the foundation
which was which was formed now cracks
and the children who were supposed to be
sheltered by and given security by this
foundation are now buried under its
rubble that's what happens
and when I say the bond is broken you
know that's not exactly the right way of
putting it I guess because according to
the Christian understanding according to
Jesus the bond cannot be broken it is
unbreakable
Jesus says this very clearly in Matthew
when he's asked about it by the
Pharisees he says haven't you read at
the beginning the creator made the male
and female for this reason a man will
leave his father and mother and be
united to his wife and the two will
become one flesh
what God has joined together let no one
separate
they are no longer two but one
means that or he doesn't
true or isn't
in in marriage we either become one with
our spouses or we don't
and if we do that we must remain one no
matter what that's why Jesus says you
can't get remarried because you're still
married to the other person
that bond is still there
that's the whole beauty and and in
miracle and power of marriage is that it
is a it's a sacrament bestowed on one
spouse to the other and vice versa
and that and then it is it is it is
sealed by God but the point is that in a
marriage ceremony something real is
actually happening there's a real thing
taking place a supernatural event you
are witnessing a supernatural event you
are witnessing two souls come together
and be to be bound together for life
it's a miracle
and this is the problem with all the
Christians today who you know they see
everything is symbolic and nothing is
sacramental and so they've lost so they
don't even understand they've taken the
significance and the beauty and the
depth out of everything and everything
now is just it's just a charade it's a
pageant it's just words that you say
nothing has any meaning but that's not
how it's supposed to be that's not what
Jesus is saying he's saying marriage has
meaning something is happening you are
doing something here something serious
and real is happening
and you can't undo it it's done
just like that
of course people people who are familiar
with the Bible will observe that Jesus
allows for an exception
supposedly
and in Matthew he does say he says
everyone who divorces his wife except on
grounds of unchastity
which is variously inter translated as
sexual immorality adultery so everyone
who divorces his wife except on those
grounds makes her commit adultery
now Matthew is the only place in the New
Testament where you find this exception
problem is that the passages in mark and
in Luke they don't contain this
exception
they also record Jesus talking about the
indissoluble indissolubility of marriage
how it's an unbreakable covenant they
don't include any exception whatsoever
and then st. Paul he discusses marriage
he talks about divorce but he but he
includes no exception he says don't get
divorced
so what's happened though is a lot of
churches and this this process really
started
long before this but in many churches it
really began to take hold in the early
20th century where they latched on to
this exception and they just are
clinging to it now desperately and
wringing it dry of every possibility and
this little a quote-unquote exception
has been used and taken and just it has
destroyed the marital covenant in
America
which is an Internet you know it's an
interesting thing when and you find this
in the Bible you know the different
Gospel accounts are a little bit
different and but when you find
something like this where Jesus says it
only in one gospel and in none of the
others
and so you you know in a sense you
almost have to choose
which one are you going to take to heart
and it's interesting that so many
Christians have I mean is interesting
they've chose that's the one
they could take mark and Luke's
interpretation but no they say well no
that's not exact but I'm gonna take this
one this is the one I like now but it is
there so we have to deal with it right I
mean we can't just write it off and
so what what is it what does it mean and
and why does it appear only in one
gospel and think about the gospel that
it appears him matthew is a gospel that
was written specially for a Jewish
audience and even in that passage Jesus
is talking to a Jewish audience he's
talking to the Pharisees
so it's Jesus talking to a Jewish
audience in a gospel written specially
for a Jewish audience and for some
reason this one interesting mysterious
vague exception appears only in that
context and nowhere else
why is that
well it seems to me that the idea that
this is really just a broad sweeping
exception allowing for a divorce
negating jesus's own teaching on
marriage allowing for divorce in any
case of unchastity or adultery well that
just doesn't hold it just doesn't make
sense it doesn't it doesn't work with
everything else in the New Testament it
doesn't work with Jesus's own words even
in the context of that passage where he
says man and wife become one flesh
and then for him to immediately a
sentence later say well but maybe not
that doesn't work
um
it also doesn't work because and again
there's there's debate about what
exactly how do you interpret that and I
mean what is the dolt sure what is mean
well Jesus also defines adultery
in Matthew by saying if you look at a
woman lustfully then you have committed
adultery
and so if we're really gonna take that
exception to heart well that means that
if a man so much as looks at a woman
that's grounds for divorce
you're done right I mean you're sitting
on a park bench with your wife a woman
walks by you look at her you can get
divorced that's it she can leave
says that's adultery in your heart and
and Jesus is being serious about that I
mean we have to take him literate we'd
take him at his word but if you lust
after a woman even for a moment in your
heart in your head then you have
committed adultery but you take that and
you apply it to what he's saying here at
least the way people interpret it then
it would seem like well you could
basically get that that means that
basically every marriage in America can
be broken
you could get out because adultery in
the heart is is sadly at an extremely
common thing in in marriages
just in America but throughout human
history right so
you know
that also doesn't work he goes that
would mean that he goes from saying
marriage is a union you know man and
woman they come together let no man
separate
and then and then a couple sentences
later he's saying well but actually
every marriage can be dissolved no
doesn't make sense but that's how it's
been interpreted
so how can we understand it well
a few different theories one theory is
that Matthew
put that in there
as a means of avoiding the whole subject
of adultery because he didn't want to
alienate his Jewish audience and so he
kind of just punted on it and he put
that in there
which is possible look the got the
Gospel writers they all you know they
they all kind of take from their
perspective in the audience they're
talking to they frame things different
it's like for instance you know most
biblical scholars agree that the Sermon
on the Mount which appears in at least
the the expanded version the Director's
Cut version that appears in Matthew it's
much longer than it appears elsewhere
because Matthew has taken teachings that
Jesus said at other points and he's kind
of put them all together into this one
cohesive unit it doesn't mean that Jesus
actually said all that right that he did
say it all but most biblical scholars
think he didn't say it right then he
said it at various point because then
other gospel gives other some teachings
from the Sermon on the Mount they
appeared in the Sermon on the Mount for
for Matthew but then other Gospels they
appear elsewhere so how do you make
sense of it you know it's because the
Gospel writers you know have their own
ways of kind of presenting things so
that's possible another is that Jesus is
that this is just a matter of wording
and that what Jesus is saying is that
anyone who divorces his wife causes her
to commit adultery unless she's already
committed adultery in whiskey in which
case he hasn't caused it because she
already committed
but I think the most logical theory and
the one that makes sense of everything
is that Matthew is speaking to people
who do marriage differently from the
rest of the world and from the way that
we do it now
and in Jewish custom at the time there
was a marriage there was a legal
marriage and then there was a period of
some time before the marriage was
consummated and that is made complete
made full through sexual relations with
husband and wife and there was this way
this is called the betrothal period
where there's a legal marriage but the
marriage is not complete yet it isn't it
has not come into its fullness yet
Jewish custom so it would make sense
that Jesus is speaking to and Matthew is
speaking to people who take part in that
custom and what he's saying is if you
commit adultery during that period
before you've consummated with your
husband or with your wife then the
marriage is dissolved and it wouldn't
even really be divorced in that case it
is illegally it's divorced but the point
is the marriage was never complete
now there's precedent for this remember
that this is what gee this is what
Joseph was going to do with Mary
originally before he came to understand
or at least in some way came to
understand what was really going on but
no he was married to her but as he said
he he had not had relations with her yet
he had not consummated the marriage so
when he thought for that moment that she
had been unfaithful he was going to
divorce her quietly to a so as to
preserve her dignity but the point is he
was going to divorce because if she had
been unfaithful then that means the
marriage is dissolved anyway so you know
it would seem that those theories make a
heck of a lot more sense than the idea
that Jesus allowed for an exception that
could apply to almost all marriages
right after he just said that marriages
are a bond eternally between man and
wife and no man can separate it you know
that to me doesn't make any sense
and especially wouldn't make any sense
that this exception this glaring huge
enormous pivotal exception would only
appear vaguely and confusingly in one
gospel and nowhere else
I think that in
modern America we have not just in
America but a modern society we have
decided to interpret it that way because
that's how we want it to be
you know I've always been someone who
has encouraged marriage I've always been
a proponent of marriage but I think I
need to add a disclaimer to that you
know you you shouldn't be afraid to
marry and I always say that I always say
to a to people in my generation don't be
afraid of marriage you know you should
you should get married if you want to
don't be afraid of it but
clamor is you shouldn't be afraid to
marry as long as the person you're
marrying has ruled out divorce as an
option to start with because if the prey
they cannot look you in the eyes and
tell you I will not leave you if they
cannot say that doe Miriam
and not only should you not marry them
it's not even just like you shouldn't
marry them it's also that you can't
marry them
later you literally cannot marry them
because in a now you could go you could
have the ceremony you could say the vows
you could have the reception you have
the honeymoon but if a person while
they're saying the vows if they don't
fully mean it and if the in the back of
their head if they're thinking yeah you
know I could leave if this thing goes
sideways if in their head they're
thinking well this is not necessarily
lifelong let's see how it goes if
they've got somewhere in their mind kind
of an escape plan in mind then it's not
a marriage the marriage wasn't valid it
wasn't valid it didn't take place
because marriage requires full consent
of the will it requires that both as I
said it's a sacrament bestowed on one
spouse to the other and if one of them
isn't taking part in that stowing in
that bestowing process if they are not
bestowing their undying commitment on
the other well then there's no marriage
there's a disconnect there you know the
the the it's it's it's the marriage is
when the two come together and connect
but when the one is not taking part and
there can't be a marriage
that's literally that's what the vow is
that's what it's all about that's why
you say the Val it's when you say to the
other person I will not leave you this
is until death do we part that's why we
say it
and if somebody won't say it or if they
will say it but they refuse to mean it
then there can't there can there
literally cannot be a marriage
you
and so I think probably in America today
there are a lot of invalid marriages
that because there are a lot of people
who go into marriage not really
intending necessarily to stay in it
they go into the marriage with this
basically the same internal commitment
as you know as as they had before the
marriage which is a yeah I'm committed
to you for now I love you for now but
I'm not promising necessarily to always
love you I may say that I promise you
but I don't really
think about prenuptial agreements
everything prenups I mean I don't see
how a marriage could be valid if there's
a prenup
because that means that what you're
saying is here's my escape plan here's
my escape strategy yeah I hope this
works out but I mean maybe it won't and
if it doesn't then here's my here's my
plan B
well then that means it's not till death
do we part
means you're not serious it's not a
marriage thought a marriage is
might be a legal marriage but it's not
really amiss spiritually it's not a
marriage what marriage is supposed to be
that's where you find the security and
the whole point and everything in
marriage you find it when you can look
at the other person and you know that
there's this commitment and you will
never leave them that you're in it
always
that's why I thought you know that's why
I it's one of the many reasons why I ice
so much prefer being married you know I
enjoy marriage so much more than I ever
did it's like the whole you know dating
and everything one of the many many
reasons is that is is that security that
you have that kind of emotional
spiritual security
and knowing that you know even if
there's hard times even if mistakes are
made even if there are times of
unhappiness and anger and everything
even if those times are numerous and
even if you go through a really rough
patch you know that you're in it you're
not going to leave because you made that
commitment and you're bound to it and by
it and through it
to not have that in a marriage as a
scary thing and
scary most of all because then it's not
really a marriage
everything I'm saying here is just
really basic biblical you know I'm just
I'm being redundant and like
plagiarizing the Bible everything I'm
saying is just right from the Bible but
and that's what makes it so sad and and
and shameful really that many Christians
will never hear anything like this in
their churches
and so the marital institution is just
collapsing all around us and most
churches and most Christian leaders
refuse to say anything about it
because their couch
Jesus was not a coward which is why he
spoke to this issue directly multiple
times and what he said was clear
and so I think we need to go back to
that
thanks for watching thanks for listening
everybody Godspeed